the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so today I want to finish up thinking
about circuits and the major topic for
today is just one thinking about
abstractions that we can use for
thinking about circuits the abstractions
are things that capitalize on linearity
and they include things like feminine
and Norton and superposition ok so what
I want to do is finish up thinking about
circuits and just to get you thinking
about circuits let's think about where
we are last time we saw that one of the
issues in thinking about circuit design
is the fact that every part in principle
interacts with every other part which
makes the design process harder than the
design process was for things like
linear systems where we thought about
boxes having inputs and outputs in
linear systems when we thought about
boxes having inputs and outputs the
output didn't necessarily have any
effect on the input unless there was an
explicit path feedback in circuits
there's feedback always there's no way
to avoid it and in fact that coupling
can make thinking about the circuits
very difficult and we we introduced that
idea by just thinking about even if you
wanted to close a switch in a circuit
that's logically the same as adding a
new part and when you do that that's
going to change the currents and
voltages everywhere so that's kind of
the big thing that's kind of the thing
that's different about circuits from
what we've been thinking about before
because that complicates design we'd
like some way of dealing with it and the
way we introduced them the way that you
used in the labs so far has been to use
a buffer we can use an op-amp to make a
buffer and the buffer has this nice
isolation property in this particular
circuit it has the property that it
copies this voltage to the output
regardless of what's at the output that
means we could put a switch here we
could change the light bulb we could do
anything we wanted to and we would still
know because of the properties of the
op-amp we would still know that this
voltage is going to be 8 volts
regardless of what we put there so
that's very nice that gives us a
modularity that gives us a way to design
things in lessons designed the left make
a circuit that generates eight volts
without knowing precisely what's going
to be the ultimate circuit that that
drives so that's nice and it allows us
to do modularity and in many instances
that's a very good solution in fact in
the solo in the problems that you're
working on in lab or you're trying to
drive a motor that's an excellent
solution it's not always an excellent
solution in some sense it's very
expensive an op-amp is a complicated
part if you were to look inside an
op-amp there's some two dozen
transistors in most op amps so it's not
an inexpensive part especially when you
think about this kind of a circuit that
only has three parts to the left the op
amp is actually a more complex device
than anything else up there so op amps
are wonderful op amps allow us to make
buffers buffers are wonderful but
they're not always the best solution for
thinking about modularity and in fact
there's other ways and so that's what we
want to think about today is other ways
for achieving modularity in circuit
design and the key to thinking about
this is to think about well what's the
worst thing that could happen if I
changed this part arbitrarily just how
bad can things get so I'll let you
answer that think about that circuit and
assume that this is a 90 volt power
supply 3 ohm 6 ohm but this can change
our not can change i've tabulated some
values of r naught and putative
corresponding values for V 0 and a 0 are
my putative answers right so take a
minute talk to your neighbor figure out
how many of these let's see 10 blue
numbers are right or wrong
it's very quiet you are allowed to talk
to people
so how many of the numbers are wrong so
raise your hand
indicate by a number of fingers how many
mistakes are in the table more votes
four votes come on come on if you had
talked more you could blame it on your
neighbor more easily so talk quickly
okay
so does everybody agree with their
neighbor okay I don't see a single right
answer so take 30 more seconds and think
about it again I don't see any right
answers so assume your answer is wrong
colorblind okay so how many of the
voltages and currents are incorrect
okay how about a revote so how many of
the the blue numbers the currents and
voltages how many of V naught and I
naught how many of those are incorrect
okay not very many votes I'd say about
80% correct now that's that's definitely
an improvement what would have to be
true how if I wanted to prove that there
at some of these numbers were wrong what
could I do
give me a condition that would have to
be true if the numbers were correct
sister better be better obey Ohm's law
that's what we mean by that symbol so it
better be the case that V naught is I
naught R naught so you you'd want this
number to be the product of that and
that so zero is the product of 0 and 30
that looks good 30 is 2 times 15 36 is 3
times 12 48 is 6 times 8 68 well that's
a little marginal how about if I
rearrange it a little bit and say what
if R is V over I if I is 0 that would
make the resistor infinity so there's a
way of thinking about that last line is
correct there's a little funny
maybe the forward way of thinking about
it is well what if I made the resistor
infinite if I made the resistor infinite
what would be I 0 and what would be V
what we do
focus fire fire relationship here six
over three plus eight times 90 which is
60 so if you straightforward reasoning
saying what if the resistor were
infinitely large what would happen then
you would conclude that the bottom lines
okay if if you choose if you share that
the R equals V over I are you done what
else has to be true in order for the
numbers to be true
so the voltages that's an instance where
you just said is an instance of KVL
basically the voltage around all the
loops better be zero sum of the voltages
around all the loops better be zero and
the sum of the currents into all the
surfaces better be zero right KVL better
be satisfied everywhere in KCl better be
satisfied everywhere
so in particular we could ask about this
node we could say do the currents
flowing into that node sum to zero so if
you take a line here let's take this
line if Z not happen to be V nought
happens to be the voltage here right so
if V nought were 36 then that puts some
voltage on on this leg right 36 would be
what 54 so then you'd have to say if you
have to compute them the current through
here and the currents through there and
see if those currents sum to zero and in
fact if you do those calculations you
can ask you can convince yourself that
those are all true so the answer was
zero although those answers were true
the point of doing the exercise was to
just remind you about how you solve
circuits but also to to let let us look
at patterns the interesting thing in
this problem is the pattern that results
between the v's and the eyes so if I
were to make a plot in fact those V's
and eyes all fall on a straight line
well that's pretty interesting so if I
plot just this V versus this eye so V
equals 0 30 36 0 30 36 48 60 and the
corresponding eyes 30 15 12 6-0 30 15 12
6-0 those points will fall on a straight
line that suggests there's some pattern
here and if there's a pattern then
there's no there might be a way to
exploit it so that's what I'm trying to
develop is a way to exploit the pattern
results when parts of circuits interact
the interesting thing that we that so
not only is it true that there's a
simple pattern but it turns out that the
pattern is completely independent of the
thing that I put on the right the
pattern is a property of the circuit to
the left one way to convince yourself of
that is the substitute take that
resistor out and put in a voltage source
and redo the problem this time instead
of assuming that there's an Ohm's law
type resistor here assume there's a
constant voltage and that constant
voltage is adjusted to zero 30 36 48 60
if you re solve that problem you get
exactly these same currents the answer
continues to fall on exactly the same
line so that's a very interesting
pattern the idea is that when the
circuit on the Left interacts with the
circuit on the right regardless of what
the circuit on the right is you get a
simple relationship between the voltage
and current that comes out of the
circuit on the left so that motivates
the idea that we can think about the
left-hand circuit as some kind of a
generic part we call that generic part
of one port think about this circuit on
the left the thing is in the red box
it's got at its terminals the terminals
are the things that poke through the red
box first off it has two terminals two
terminals is just like all of our other
parts and a cycle resistor it's like a
voltage source it's like a current
source it's a two terminal device and
just like a voltage source or a resistor
or a current source there's some voltage
across those terminals and there's some
current that flows in those terminals so
there's some current that goes into plus
and that same current comes out from -
that'll be true for this circuit just
the same as it's true for a resistor or
voltage source or anything else the only
difference is the thing that's inside
the box in
the thing that's inside the one port is
more complicated than it was for a
simple resistor or voltage or a current
saris so what we can think about is this
whole red box just looks like a super
part so the interesting thing that
happens is it's this red box behaves
like a warm pour it like a super part
and just like a resistor has a
relationship between V and I V equals IR
or a voltage source has some kind of a
constraint V equals V naught or a
current source has some kind of a
constraint I equals I not this this
funny part has a relationship between V
and I that's given by that curve in some
sense it's not very different so we
think then so what we want to do now is
figure out the rules that govern the
currents and voltages that flow through
one ports and in particular how special
was this straight line thing I mean if
they were always a straight line that'd
be really easy right so the question so
the next question I'd like to ask is
just how often are we expecting to see
straight lines there well I already said
the primitive elements that we think
about owns all resistors voltage sources
current sources they have straight lines
constraints between the voltages and
currents that they can generate so think
about what I'm doing I'm trying to think
about a rule that's gonna let me
describe the currents and voltages into
that red box from the previous slide
much like I would describe the voltages
and currents in a in an Ohm's law
resistor I can tell you the voltage
current relationship V equals IR for
homes owned resistor independent of what
it's connected to
that's the reasoning that I'm using here
I'm going to try to figure out
independent of what is connected to what
will be the voltage current relationship
for the red box so the question is when
are we expecting straight lines of when
are we not
expecting straight lines so here's a
simple circuit here's a super part made
out of one linear resistor one Ohm's law
resistor and one voltage source what's
the current voltage relationship for
that part what if I put a red box around
the whole thing and ask you to draw the
IV curve the current voltage curve which
would it look like ABCD which should
have been 1 2 3 4 so you can raise
fingers or none of the above
so take 30 seconds figure out what would
be the IV curve for this part
so if you map a 2 d into 1 to 4 which of
those plots describes the current
voltage relationship for that circuit
map a 2 D to one before okay you're
quiet and the success rate is smaller
than usual
okay bout 50% correct okay 30 seconds
reconsider your answer try to get this
up to 85% as old
so which is the best plot which plot
best characterizes the circuit on the
top okay that's much better that's by
75% certainly not 100% but better okay
so how do you think about this one way
to think about it is special cases can
you think of any special cases that are
particularly easy to check zero okay
what equals zero Veera yeah so what do
you were to make eyes zero if you were
to make I equal to zero first off if you
made ie who to zero what's special in
the plots you do have any run up attack
if you take a zero what will be if you
make a V zero then if there won't be
defroster user so the total voltage here
will be the same as the voltage across
the voltage source V was five so the
intersection on the x-axis should be at
the point V equals five make sense now
if you set V equals zero how big would I
be
so how did he say what's the serpent way
of saying zero
you said equals zero inserted by Brandon
I sent by trimming the wire so you no
matter wider than even here voltage
across the wire zombies right right so
you said second to zero by putting a
wire across it we call that a short
circuit okay there's a short path for
the voltage to travel so you put a short
circuit here and then I becomes V over R
and the only trick is it's up right
current likes to flow down the
electrochemical gradient so I'd like to
go down the the the electrical gradient
so the currents going to go up but the
reference direction for this eye is down
so I is minus two point five so the
intersection on this axis is minus two
point five so we know that it has to go
through a negative point on the bottom
and it has to go through a positive V on
the x-axis and the only curve that does
that is a and if we want it to be a
little bit more fancy we could figure
out the general rule we could just write
an expression for V R well by KVL VR is
always the difference between V and 5
volts and we could write an expression
for the current through the resistor
that's just V over R VR is V minus 5 R
is 2 so I get some expression which is
lo and behold
linear in V so just like that more
complicated circuit that I looked at I
ended up with a straight line
relationship in the current voltage the
relationship between the current and
voltage falls on a straight line
so how special is that well it actually
happens pretty robustly think about what
would happen if I had two parts there
generically I'm thinking about these as
being generic boxes inside could be
anything there could be a current source
a voltage source a linear resistor or
some other one point so if I had a
generic box here and a generic box here
and I connected them in parallel under
the condition that each of the generic
boxes had a straight line current
voltage relationship it's easy to argue
that the resulting relationship between
current and voltage for the parallel
combination is also a straight line all
you need to do is realize that if you
hook two things in parallel the parallel
voltage is the same as v1 and v2 so all
the voltages are the same and the
currents add so IP the current into the
parallel combination is the sum of the
two eyes so if you think about the
relationship between v1 and i1 and the
relationship between v2 and i2 you could
derive the relationship between IP and
VP by just adding v1 equals v2 equals VP
that's what we saw here and the current
at the bottom is the sum of the other
two currents so in particular if this
was a straight line and that was a
straight line the sum of two straight
lines is a straight line right if you
add two straight lines you get a new
straight line so what this shows is that
if you started with parts that were
themselves straight lines parallel
combinations we generate a new part with
another straight line same sort of thing
happens if the two parts were in series
in series we would have I Series is the
same as i1 equals i2 so that's
equivalence of the y-axis where
previously we had equivalence of the
x-axis and now if both of these boxes
had linear IV curves
I would now add horizontally rather than
add
vertically but I have the same result if
the two individual one ports have linear
IV curves and if I add horizontally I'll
get a new linear IV curve and in fact if
you start if you put any combination of
parts that have linear IV curves
together to form a new circuit a new one
for it the IV curve for that new one
part will be a linear function and the
way to see that is to think about linear
equations remember when we solve a
circuit we have to have one law for
every element like Ohm's law it's V
equals IR or voltage sources V whose V
naught or something like that
we need one law for every element and
then we have KVL and KCl well all of the
if we start with the assumption that
each component has a straight line
relationship between voltage and current
which is true for linear resistors
voltage sources and current sources
those equations that describe those
parts are what we call linear equations
linear equation is a as in equation an
equation where the function of the
unknowns is a quote linear function it
has the form some constant times an
unknown
plus some other constant times some
other unknown plus in principle any
number of those but it has to be a
linear function so you're not allowed to
have things like V squared in there but
if you think about things like voltage
sources and current sources and and
Ohm's law they don't have squares in
there there are linear equations and the
idea then when we're solving for the IV
relationship for this new one port thing
all we're doing is we're solving a
system of linear equations sort of in
the abstract the idea is that we write
down all the component equations inside
the box we
right on all the relevant KVL and KCl
and then we solve so they're all going
to have their each one of those
equations is going to be linear so it's
going to be something like say a 0 X 0
if X is my unknown X could be a current
or a voltage and then I might have some
of x1 that I might have some of x2 and I
might have a whole bunch of things and
they all add together to be some
constant like that so that might
represent part one that might represent
one of the components in the box then I
would have another component which would
be some other linear equation then I
have a KCl equation while KCl is easy
because that only has currents in it and
the multipliers are all one or minus one
right so that's clearly linear and I
have KVL equations those are linear and
the point is that when you solve linear
equations you get a new linear equation
so think about solving this by the
method of substitution I could figure
out what is X naught here if I use this
equation to figure out X naught X naught
would be a linear function of all the
other X's so then if I plug that linear
function into here I replace this linear
equation with a new linear equation with
one fewer unknown if I keep doing that I
just keep replacing linear equations
with other linear equations when I'm all
done I'm left with a new linear equation
that's why if you start with parts that
have linear IV curves you end up with a
straight line IV curve so that idea that
the IV function is a straight line is
quite robust it will happen any time you
build a circuit out of ideal parts where
by ideal parts I mean Ohm's law
resistors voltage sources and current
sources so that has a very interesting
circuit interpretation if I know that
arbitrary circuit can be represented by
a straight line if the IV curve can be
represented by a straight line
well that generates an equivalent set
there's obviously more than one circuit
that could generate the same straight
line here's a circuit that can generate
that straight line in fact it will
always be true that I can generate a
circuit with one voltage source and one
owns all resistor that will mimic the
behavior of any arbitrary combination of
resistors voltage sources and current
sources all I need to do is think about
you take the complicated thing figure
out its straight line plot now you read
off some critical numbers from this plot
you say okay well what if the current
were zero well if the current were zero
I'd be on this axis if the current were
zero in the circuit V would be V naught
so that means you look over here you
figure out the x-intercept and the
x-intercept is the value of the voltage
source similarly if you figure out the
rate of growth of I so more generally if
you if you solve for I I will be the
difference between V and V naught
divided by R that's just Ohm's law for
the resistor and that then unless you
figure out the law for the slope the
slope over here is going to turn out to
be 1 over this resistor I should have
had this should be R naught these two
should match so the slope of this line
is 1 over that resistor so in general
regardless of how complicated the box is
figure out the straight line in IV
curves read off the x-axis read off the
slope and that lets you construct a
simple circuit that has the same VI
curve we call that circuit the Thevenin
equivalent what that means is you can
think about a complicated circuit
regardless of how many parts by a
circuit that just has to that's an
abstraction that lets us think more
simply about complicated circuits even
if there's no buffers this is true
always okay it's not true it's not it's
not the case that if I change the thing
that I could hear if I change the thing
I put here this relationship is still
true it's the equivalent of Ohm's law
for a complicated circuit Ohm's law is
what I get if what's in the box is a
single resistor if what's in the box is
complicated more generally this is what
I get the feminine equivalent of course
there's lots of circuits that have this
IV curve so a different one is a current
source with a resistor
that's called a Norton equivalent you do
the same sort of thing what would happen
if here if I set V to be zero well how
do I make vb zero I make V be zero then
I grate that on slide 19 right in those
life I make vb zero by putting a short
circuit here I connect a wire if I put a
wire here then how big is the current I
well if I put a wire here it's easier
for this current to go through the wire
than it is to go through that resistor
so all of this current goes through the
wire all of this current is I naught so
if I put a short circuit across V if I
make me be zero how big is I minus I
naught right all of the current I naught
goes through it just goes through
backwards so that's how I get this point
so if I wanted to replace some
complicated circuit with a Norton
equivalent I would take the newer I
would take the complicated system figure
out the IV curve
read off the intercept on this axis
change the sign right that's the most
confusing part by the way that this is
the error that you all make there's a
minus sign in the current relationship
we like to draw it just makes us feel
good to have the arrow go up and if you
make the arrow go up it's in the wrong
direction to I so it when we did the
Thevenin equivalent there was no sign
flip this was V not so the voltage on
the voltage source is equal to the x
intercept but when we do the norton the
current in the current source is minus
the y-intercept same idea though okay so
the idea is that Thevenin and Norton
equivalent circuits are equivalent in
the sense that they generate the same
voltage that the more complicated
circuit did so that means for thinking
about the circuit we can ignore the
complicated stuff and just know two
numbers V naught and R naught or I
naught in are not so one more step what
this all means is that if you can
represent the current voltage
relationship for an arbitrary circuit in
terms of a straight line that means when
we're trying to characterize an
arbitrary circuit doesn't matter how
complicated it is it could have a
hundred parts in it regardless of how
complicated it is I only need to measure
two things in order to fully
characterize it if a circuit is made out
of linear resistors voltage sources and
current sources three special linear
parts if a circuit is composed entirely
out of linear parts doesn't matter how
many parts are in it there could be a
hundred there could be a thousand I only
need to measure two things to get a
complete description and that's because
two points determine a straight line I
know
having proved it by using linear algebra
I know by using linear algebra that the
solution is a straight line I know from
geometry that two points determine a
straight line I only need to find out
two points so by convention the easiest
two points is usually the simplest cases
set the voltage to zero and set the
current is B zero so that motivates the
idea that if I have an arbitrary circuit
if I want to figure out this reduced
complexity abstraction say I want to
make a Thevenin equivalent what I would
do is first ask the question how big is
the open circuit voltage open circuit
means there's no connection between the
terminals that means the current is zero
if the current is zero I'm on the x axis
so over here I'm on the x axis so I'm
thinking about the red point open
circuit over here means there's no
connection here which means the current
is zero and all I need to ask is
regardless of how complicated is the
circuit how big is the voltage that I
would measure here so in this circuit if
I have a yeah I've I confused myself
remember if this current is zero then
this voltage drop is zero this voltage
source prescribes the voltage between
these nodes to be one volt
so V naught is 1 volt so I just found
one point I said I to be zero
I found the open circuit voltage then I
need to find one other point because I
only need to find two so I'll find the
short circuit current imagine that I put
a wire between the input and the output
and I'll compute how much current this
circuit generates in that wire again the
only confusing part is that the
reference directions are backwards to
the way you might have expected them to
be if I put a short circuit here then
the voltage between these nodes is still
1 volt that's what the voltage source
always says
so the current that flows through this
wire the short-circuit current is just
this V over that are except this in the
negative direction and the way you can
think about that is that the slope of
this curve has to be positive I need
because of the weight Ohm's law works
increasing the voltage better tend to
increase the current because that's what
Ohm's law resistors do so I need to have
this slope be positive if if it's going
to be Ohm's law
so I characterized just those two points
and then the resistance is simply the
ratio of the two so the resistance is
related to the slope it's one over the
slope you don't need to worry about that
the resistance is always V over I so you
just take the open circuit voltage and
divide by the short-circuit current
minus sign and you get that the resistor
must be 2 ohms that'll clear the idea is
that we're trying to build an
abstraction that lets us simplify the
way we think about circuits without
introducing buffers so that means then
that these two circuits are equivalent
to that circuit in the sense that they
all share the same VI curve if you
substituted one circuit for the other
you couldn't tell from the from outside
the red box which was on the inside of
the red box
ok so I'll do an example now think about
what if I wanted to find the equivalent
the Thevenin equivalent for this circuit
I just do the things I just told you to
do first thing I think about is what's
the open circuit voltage so if I think
about open circuit there's no connection
here that means this current is zero
that means that the voltage that
develops is the voltage divider so I get
seven and a half volts 3 over 1 plus 3
times 10 right
so that gives me one point that tells me
the voltage source for the 17 equivalent
then for the second point I want to
think about the short-circuit current so
I consider putting a wire here and then
I compute the amount of current that
flows in that wire and in this circuit
this wire shorts out that resistor so
all the current goes through this wire
and none of the current goes through
that resistor so that means that the
total current that flows is 10 volts
divided by 1 ohm which is 10 amps and
then I know that the equivalent
resistance is the ratio of the open
circuit voltage to the short circuit
current except how to worry about the
minus sign and so I end up with the
equivalent resistance being the 7.5
volts which is the open circuit voltage
divided by 10 amps so I get 0.75 ohms
and so the answer then is that here's
the circuit I started with here's the
seven in the equivalent circuit they're
identical in the sense that they have
the same VI curve and you can just sort
of see why that has to be true if you
think about here's the two circuits and
if you think about the simple cases if
you set I to be zero the voltage is
better be the same well over here it's
7.5 by the voltage divider over here is
7.5 by the fact that there's no current
going through that resistor and the
short circuit current better be the same
so over here if you short this out
you're gonna get 10 amps over here if
you short it out you're gonna get 10
amps so you can always go back and forth
the point is that you can substitute the
simpler circuit for the more complex
circuit because they have the same VI
curve okay just to make sure that you're
following me here's a question that has
to do with taking the same circuit but
considering the Thevenin equivalent
seven a Norton equivalent at three
different ports here I'm thinking about
what would happen if I looked in
Terminal A what if I looked in Terminal
B or looked in terminal C figure out the
seven and
and Norton parameters and see if there's
an eight and error in the piggy
so how many errors are in the table
about 50% correct again
so which entry don't you like I need to
figure out for the a circuit how big
would be the voltage across a if there
was no current flowing in the leg of a
everybody clear on that so the thing
that I would do is I think about there's
no connection here what's the voltage
here so how would I calculate that yeah
the current that goes in this leg
compared to that leg is the ratio of
this resistance to the some resistance
right and if you work that out you're
gonna get 4 amps coming through here so
then after you know the current through
this leg it's an easy matter to take the
current and turn it into a voltage so
the voltage of the aiport is 4 amps
times 5 ohms is 20 volts exactly and
similarly that with a different answer
the voltage of the B terminal is the
same 4 amps but now times 10 ohms so
that's how we got 40 and at C it's the
same 4 amps but now it's times the sum 4
times 15 is 60
everybody's happy about that so the
point is that when you generate an
equivalent circuit it depends upon which
set of terminals you use
you can't just take a circuit and say
give me the Thevenin equivalent you have
to say give me the Thevenin equivalent
looking somewhere so I could look in the
a port the B port or the seaport and I
get different V knots how would I
compute the I 9 out when I do that all
of the current flows in this leg and
none of the current flows that way so
that means I have equivalently 10 ohms
in parallel with 10 ohms then by the
current divider how much current goes
down one leg half of it I get a
different answer over here because now I
sure doubt that node which sure it's out
that resistor so now I get a different
ratio of resistors it's not the same as
the first so I know that this answer
can't be five and in fact if you're
working out the answer is 20 over three
and finally if you sure here then you
know that that short circuit shorts out
both this series combination and that
one so all of the 10 amps goes through
that so you get that 10 amps then how do
you get R nought or it's just the ratio
of V naught over I naught so if you take
V naught over I naught you get four here
if you do the right answer you get six
and here if you do that you get six the
point is that the seven and equivalent
that you get is different the Norton
equivalent that you get is different
depending on which ports you're looking
at okay there's two reasons for thinking
about this one so why am I thinking
about all these equivalent circuits so I
wanted to have on an abstraction that
was useful for thinking about how parts
interact
I wonder the way of thinking about what
would happen if I change the load on a
circuit without having to recalculate
all the voltages and currents throughout
the circuit and so this 7 and then
Bolton and Norton idea is a way of doing
that that's important from a practical
sense because when you buy a part when
you buy an electronic part they tell you
how it works by telling you the Thevenin
equivalent or the Norton equivalent or
whatever is the easy way to think about
it so there's a practical reason when
you buy an op-amp they tell you how good
the op-amp is by telling you how big is
the equivalent resistance at the output
so it has a practical value because it
lets you it's the way you specify an
electronic part you can't win you when
the manufacturer makes a part they can't
know what you're going to do with it
so they tell you how it works by telling
you the something about the equivalent
circuit it's there's also a different
reason for thinking about this and that
is because it's conceptually simplifying
to think about 7 + + norton equivalence
so here's an example that's very much
like the first problem that I worked out
what would be the effect of closing this
switch on the current I we solved the
problem very much like this last time
and one way you can solve it is you
figure out I in two cases when the
switch is open and when the switch is
closed and you figure out whether it run
up or down and you know the answer the
point is that if you think about this in
terms of equivalent circuits it's
completely trivial if I think about what
would happen I'm interested in what
happens at I what I do is split the
circuit into two pieces the stuff to the
left of I and the stuff to the right of
my eye I make it seven equivalent for
both of them and then I jam together the
two thousand eight equivalence what I
get in detail is showed here so if I
look left I see a 20 volt source with a
4 4 and a 2 that has an equal and the
equivalent this showed here which is
independent of the state of the switch
so the same 7 occurs on the two sides
switch open or switch closed
if I make it seven and over here there's
no sources so it's just going to be a
resistance so when the switch is open I
have two ohms when the switch is closed
I have one over I don't even need to
figure out what are these part values to
see that if I make this resistance
smaller which happens if I close the
switch the current goes up I mean it's
true that I showed here that the seven
in voltage is 10 and the Thevenin
resistor is four I don't even care
regardless of what the feminine voltage
was regardless of what the Thevenin
current is it's going to be the same
when the switch is open and closed and
that's a powerful statement I know it's
the same so when I close the switch all
I've really done is I've made that
resistor smaller the net series
resistance is down the current is up so
I there's two reasons for thinking about
seven and a Norton equivalence one is
practical value the other is conceptual
simplicity it lets you simplify the way
you think about a circuit and it's a way
of gaining intuition without ever even
solving the equations most circuit
designers don't solve circuit equations
they know what is going to do just by
looking at it and this is the kind of
reasoning that they use okay there's one
more topic the idea of evidence and
Norton's really derived from linear
algebra the basic parts of most interest
are linear and when you put together a
system out of linear parts you get a
linear system there's one more
consequence of linearity that is
terribly useful and that's the idea of
superposition if you have a system of
equations thus linear and if you have
multiple sources things are very simple
it's you can see that over here if I had
multiple sources the system of equations
that I get wouldn't look quite like this
this these terms the constant terms
they're the ones that come from the
drives the voltage sources the current
sources so if I had two drives I would
get something else here I would get plus
a and plus one
for example Soros one source to and I
would get source one source two so the
idea is that if I have a system that has
multiple sources I know from the
structure of the linear equations
there's just more constant terms okay
we're like what's that mean that means
you can just use linear algebra to see
that the answer to this problem is the
sum of the answers to that problem plus
the answers to that problem
that's just linear algebra what that
means in terms of circuits is I can
figure out the response to a circuit by
turning on the sources one at a time
that's called superposition and
generally speaking it's a lot easier
than solving the circuit out the long
way so here I've got two sources so say
I wanted to compute I in response to V
naught and I naught what I would do is I
would turn off the I naught source and
calculate the voltage that results just
from the voltage source that's the same
as setting this to zero and finding the
response to this so if I want to set I
to zero the way you set I to be zero is
open circuit if you open circuit
something there's no current going to
flow through it so I replace the current
source with an open circuit and compute
the I that would result when the current
source isn't there okay well that's easy
if the current source were not there
this would be an open circuit the
current I would just be the total
voltage going through r1 and r2 so the
answer I 1 the first component of the
current I would be V naught the result
of the voltage source divided by the sum
of r1 and r2 now that's not the whole
answer that would be the whole answer if
I naught weren't there tonight I have to
worry about the other case
what if only I not were there well now I
have to set V to be zero well setting V
to 0 is not open circuiting it you can't
just reach in grab the voltage source
and throw it away because that'll make
the current zero if I want the voltage
to be zero I have to short-circuit it so
what I do then is I read leave the
current source alone and I replace the
voltage source with a short-circuit
guaranteeing the via zero then I ask how
big is I to the component of I that
results from the current source well if
I short-circuited this then I just get a
current divider this current has to do
it how readily the current divides
between r1 and r2 the amount that goes
through the R one side is in proportion
to our to make r2 bigger or more of it
goes through r1 standard current divider
except for the slippery minus sign so if
I only had the current source the
current i2 would have been current
divider operating on I not with the
slippery minus sign so that means by
superposition that the result of having
both sources on is just the sum of those
answers that's a very big simplification
if you've got multiple sources in a
circuit you can think about them all at
once and if you're really good at
writing linear equations and solving
them with pencils you'll get the right
answer but there's an enormous
simplification if you just turn off all
but one and do them one at a time so
here's a problem here's a very simple
circuit compute V using superposition V
is the voltage across the resistor how
big would V be if you use the idea of
superposition
so what's the answer
fifty percent correct
roughly speaking okay one of you super
position so how big with the voltage VB
if all I had was the voltage source one
how big would the voltage be if I only
had the current source ah got half of
you that explains to the 50% correct how
big would the voltage be if I only had
the current source it's tempting to say
what I say that's what's wrong about the
answers one what's the voltage to the
current source won't be true the current
source is the voltage the current sort
of Garrett is the voltage source weren't
there if the voltage source weren't
there then half of you got it right so
half of you can shout the answer so if
the voltage source weren't there the
voltage that the voltage source would be
zero if the voltage at the voltage
source were zero then V would be zero so
the voltage due to the voltage source is
one the voltage due to the current
source is zero the sum of the two is one
the answer is one okay make sense so
very closely related problem what's the
current I solve that by superposition
so how big is the current I according to
superposition wonderful so how big is
the current I generated by the voltage
shorts one how many's the current I
generated by the currents were trivial
by superposition they're not too hard by
not superposition but the point is that
they're trivial by superposition so what
we saw the day the the goal for the day
was to generate some abstractions that
you let you think about the way parts
interact with each other
because that's an a central issue when
you're thinking about circuit design and
we built the idea of seven ins and
norton's and superpositions that that
was the basic idea and the sub theme or
maybe I should say the major theme is
really that it's the importance of
linear algebra so the take-home message
is probably take 1806 so this was all
about the application of 1806 to the
solving of circuits see you later